-So, your show
is called "Forever."
-Yes.
-And other than the fact
that you are a married couple
in this show,
not much is known about it.
I've watched the first episode,
which was wonderful,
but I feel as though
I still do not fully know
all the twists that are coming.
Is it difficult to talk about
this show because of that?
-It's a little difficult
to talk about it,
but we can still say
that it's about, uh --
Is being together forever,
in the true meaning
of the word "forever" --
Is that a good thing?
Wouldn't that get boring?
-Hmm.
-Or is it great?
-Hmm!
-And in real life...
In real life,
what would be the best thing
about being married to Fred?
-Oh, great question. Um...
[ Laughter ]
We would have a good time.
-I think so, too.
-We would make up
a lot of pretend songs.
-Yeah. I -- This is --
We did not discuss this
beforehand,
but I feel like
anytime I do a fake song,
if I ever sing, she always
does the harmony right away.
-Oh, so when you make up a fake
song, it's immediately elevated.
-Yeah.
-Yes, immediately.
-We wrote a fake song called
"I Love Punk Rock."
But it's a very sweet song.
-How does "I Love Punk Rock" go?
-♪♪ I love punk rock ♪♪
-♪♪ I really love it ♪♪
-♪♪ It is my favorite ♪♪
♪♪ I love punk rock ♪♪
-♪♪ I really love it ♪♪
-That was real.
We really did -- Yeah. Yeah.
-We also wrote a reggae song
called "Ana Gasteyer."
-You wrote a reggae song about
our old colleague Ana Gasteyer.
-Yeah, it was like...
-♪♪ Ana Gasteyer ♪♪
-♪♪ Ana, Ana, Ana, Ana ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-We are very prolific.
-Yeah.
-Is there a downside to being
married to either one of you
that you would have,
that you can see?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't think of any right now.
-I can't think of any,
my dear bud and pal.
-Yeah. I really can't.
-No.
I think -- The only thing
is he likes to get up early.
That I know.
-Oh, yeah.
I don't think I knew that
about you.
-Right? Well, 'cause when we
worked together, he's like,
"Oh. I get up two hours
before I have to -- my call."
I'm like, "What? Why?"
-Well, you -- And you're --
With four children, they must
wake you up fairly early.
-Yeah, I'm up all night.
It's a mess.
Are you happy --
This is Amazon Prime.
Are you happy with
your working relationship
with Amazon thus far?
-Yeah, except I keep reading
that they made like
a trillion dollars.
And, so, they have this thing
where they're trying to find,
like, a new headquarters.
And I feel like,
"Why don't they ask me?"
-Okay.
-I'm right there.
Why don't they ask me,
"Where is our new headquarters
going to be?"
-Well, don't you feel like
they're doing tons of research
and diving deep into finding out
what would best support
a giant company like Amazon?
-That fee--
I understand your point.
I see where
you're going with this.
And that's fair.
So, I'll let you speak.
But, um, that's more corporate.
You know what I'm saying?
That's like a corporate view.
-Well, they're a corporation.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very good point.
So I stand corrected.
-Well, like, if Jeff Bezos
came to you and said,
"Where should we go?"
what would you say?
I really, for real,
I would say Pittsburgh.
-Okay. Well, I think Pittsburgh
is actually in the running.
-Yeah. Oh, is it?
-Yeah.
-Oh, great.
-I think you maybe said it
because now you want it
to look like you named it.
-Yeah. By the way, yeah.
-That's not the case.
-Let's be clear.
I think that's the case.
-What about Orlando?
Disney World?
-Why are you changing your mind?
-Don't go back on Pittsburgh.
-What about Disney World?
They get to use the castle.
-The castle?
-They get to use the rides.
You know what I mean?
-"The castle."
-I don't feel like Disney
would want to let Amazon
use the castle.
-They could ask them.
They could ask.
Like, "Hey, can we use
the castle? Do you mind?"
-"Please, sir, please?"
-"Please?"
-They would say "please"
like that.
-"Please, sir, please, sir.
I beg Your Highness."
-Well, I'm just really glad you
guys are working with Amazon.
I think it's gonna work
out great. Thank you
both for being here.
It's always just the best
having you round.